coming up next you dated three Violent
Men yeah stupid please I've actually had
nothing but good guys to come towards me
since I just I've been taking my time
whether I want to be in a relationship
with someone or not because you you with
a man and you tell them you don't want
to be with him anymore he starts crying
and blubbering what would you do how
would you feel what would you say most
girls go back after they get cheated on
you know did you have particular sexual
positions I just want to put it out
there nicely
I have to ask so if you wanted to get
back with you tomorrow would you do it
I'm rude I'm rooting for it I mean
how many relationships have you guys
ended and why
I've only been in one so and it's not
ended so zero
three three
and why'd you end them
um it just wasn't good towards me all
violent
oh violent you dated three Violent Men
yeah stupid Please
first time it's okay like you wonder
like yeah okay it happens to anyone
second time I should have seen the red
flags but I didn't and now the third
time I just feel like I need to write
muggle my forehead do you know men that
aren't violent no I do I know a lot of
men which are my friends it just makes
no sense I just go for the ones that
they show they're nice at first and then
it's like once they grab hold of me
they don't want me to go so they'll do
anything in any type of force I.E and
you saw no red flags at the beginning
a couple two of them yes uh one of them
no I just like Wonder because if I was a
guy listening to this I'd be like why
would I be nice to you because you don't
like like you know the nice guys but you
don't pick up and you just keep um if
anything like it would incentivize them
to be abusive she does the thing I think
like
normally like I would feel like a guy
would come to me thinking oh she's been
in free relationships that have just
been violent but I've actually had
nothing but good guys to come towards me
since I just I've been taking my time
whether I want to be in a relationship
with someone or not because I really
don't want to go to a fourth time and
that's it I will be getting mug tattooed
on my forehead
yeah
what about you
they're only 19. yeah
um have I ended a religion I have ended
one
um and I think I ended it just because I
think I just wasn't I wasn't ready for
the commitment
um yeah
fickle
I think I just wasn't ready I think it
was kind of like
I was just like yeah nah and it kind of
just shut me off completely like after
that it was kind of like I don't know
why I did it nothing it's just
completely cut off and it was like I
didn't feel the same way anymore
and that was literally the end of it
there's no more to that than it than I'm
saying but yeah
I think we you said you would too
internships and you ended one no no I
didn't know the one they ended both I'm
more of a stay in a relationship make it
work kind of person then jump off and
give up
by having said that the first person
wasn't a great person so once he left
and he had made that choice it was taken
away from me so then I could then go and
be happy so I was actually grateful that
he ended it and that's why I didn't let
him come back I actually understand that
thinking because when it's like if they
break up with you you don't really have
a choice in it so you don't have to like
guess if it was the right choice because
it wasn't your choice yeah it's easier
to detach when someone else breaks up
with you than it is to for you to break
up with them do you think women ever try
to get guys to break up with them yeah
100 yeah all they do everything I feel
like that happens all the time I feel
like if you're in a relationship where
you just feel like it's kind of like
he's sometimes maybe a bit more
committed but maybe not in the way that
you want it to be you're probably going
to do everything in your power for him
to be like yeah I'm not trying like
you're doing Madness whereas that's not
actually you but it's kind of like
you're provoking that because it's just
like you don't it's kind of like you see
it but then at the same time you don't
and it's like it's easier like I can't
cool it off because he has valid points
so therefore I'm going to provoke
whatever situation it is to make him
break up with me so that I can just be
like cool you broke up with me and I'll
leave it as it is and just let them case
rest yeah I just want to jump off
something that you said a moment ago
where um a lot of times say if you get
broken up with it's easier for you to
move on um I kind of think with women
it's the opposite because when we break
up with someone we break up with them
with them in our head and then you know
six weeks later then we break up with
them so I thought perhaps it'd be a
little easier
if we leave someone because often we've
planned it you know for a lot of women
there's a guy already waiting
um whereas if you get broken up with
especially if you think things are going
fine it's this you know complete change
of circumstances sprung upon you so I
thought perhaps that would make it a
little worse actually yeah you're
probably right actually now that I'm
thinking about it because if things were
going well like that probably would
devastate me yeah but it's like yeah
yeah but it's kind of like if you're
fighting already you know if you're
fighting already you've probably
mentally checked out as well you just
wait for one or the other person to do
it I actually do agree with you like
that's never happened when it was like I
guess you know
do you think that women detach quicker
than men
depends on a woman
I feel like okay
I feel like women detach quicker than
men most of the time like if she has 10
relationships like eight or nine of them
but there's like one guy that like she
cannot detach from okay like like and I
use it because you can see it in pop
culture like a lot of 100 a lot of the
movies that like women love like Titanic
The Notebook what is it what is it about
about that guy it's like the lady in the
Titanic is like 90 talking about her
High School fling yeah and she's still
talking about that and same with the
notebook it's her going back to that guy
from high school yeah so I feel like
unless it's like that guy like women
typically get over it easier than Matt
but if you're like that guy to her then
she doesn't
um I thought the reason why I say women
get over men quickly is because I think
be aware more of an emotional we're
going through more of an emotional time
than men are
um I feel like you're in certain
situations where if something happens
it's kind of like you feel it way more
than you would feel than your
significant other would feel and then
yeah fair enough no I thought so I'm
talking more from my experience is what
I'm trying to say I feel like there's
I'm a very emotional person if something
happens
um my emotions is in it 100 and it's
kind of like if something keeps
happening I'll kind of I'll kind of get
used to it and I'll kind of be like cool
whatever so if so if you're involved in
a relationship where like things will
keep constantly happening they'll get to
a point you like you'll actually get to
a point where you're kind of like yeah
like he could do something and I just
completely like I won't react the same
way anymore and it kind of just you like
the relationship will end and you kind
of just like cool whatever because you
already felt what you need to felt
during the relationship so why she's not
going through heartbreak after definite
women just underestimate men's emotions
yeah I think women are just out there
crying and blubbering and whatever and
the men just take it because if they had
to turn around and cry and blubber I
mean if you're the man and yeah there
must be women that square with men and
they just start crying what did you
think about them lose total respect for
them yeah that's why they don't do it
they just deal with it but women God
damn blood all their friends will come
around and always done this so he's done
that and man they're trying to travel so
you're telling me women lose respect for
men that core would cry to you oh my God
yeah of course I swear you wanna okay
you want a guy leading you
imagine the CEO of a company just crying
in front of his employees it's the same
thing with the relationship you're not
going to respect a guy's leadership the
same way if he's crying all the time can
I ask because I never cried in front of
you
um I've had people be emotional towards
me and it hasn't made me really lose
respect for you because I feel like a
fair both like established that type of
relationship you can't cry to me I'll
look at you like cool let me put it this
way right you use with a man and you
tell me you don't want to be with him
anymore and he starts crying and
blubbering what would you do how would
you feel that's kind of different that's
what we mean that's what we're talking
about even my pride wouldn't let me cry
for someone if they broke up with me I
thought you said that you that women cry
and get emotional when they get when
they were split up with a man
pardon I thought you said that women cry
and they get emotional when they split
up with a man I mean they do right so
I'm saying turning on it said what if it
was a man that's better with a woman and
he's the one that's blubbering
I mean cool like if you're crying then
you care didn't it like I don't I don't
know what you actually want me to do how
would you feel towards him do you think
it'd make you want to get back with him
and then like would you be more
attracted to him or less attracted to
him
if it depends on who it is yeah if he
yeah it depends on who it is if you look
ugly crying though sorry
but yeah it actually depends who it is
like 100 but I think that girls usually
and I can say this from having not from
my own experience but from friends who
go through this uh one of my friends
um said to me when we're on first time
um that she had an argument with her
boyfriend
um and essentially she did it just to
see if he would like kind of chase after
him face timer and call her and you know
lo and behold 50 no caller ID calls and
she said to me well like I don't really
want him to be doing that like I want to
go after him and I thought it was quite
strange because you know you'd think
that you'd want someone to come after
you and you know chase after but
typically you know women attracted
unfortunately to toxicity so
um yeah but is it not toxic to be
harassing someone like that of course
that's of course that's toxic
um but I'm saying in terms of
in terms of the relationship
um a lot of time
how to explain it
um it's toxic to be harassing someone
um but it's also you know toxic to leave
someone that you love with no final word
which is what she would see that
relationship as but for some reason
that's what she would gravitate more to
than someone that's trying to get her
back yeah that's what that's what I
meant I'm a cut and go you lie to me I'm
gone you cheat I'm gone
going back there
no no no no why no why should I and then
you're gonna cheat again they're gonna
cheat again okay what if he told you
like Auntie like I'm the best woman that
any man that has ever been with me you
cheat on me there's not going back I'm
moving on but cool what have you told
you or like cool I saw us together but I
had to go confide another woman to make
me realize that you're the one I'm
looking for I'm gonna keep on going then
keep on thinking no if you lied to me
from the beginning you have to set the
rules down from the beginning and if I
have a man you know don't lie to me
don't you if you lie it's over if you
cheat it's over I don't care why
is over finishing no conversation is
done because women say oh you know if he
cheats on me you know and then what he's
going to do again he's gonna do again
he's gonna do it again if I told you
once it's gone it's finished it's gone
and if you cry it's even worse and
you're even stupid to believe him if he
says he's never gonna do it again but
what if he doesn't do it men most
probably wouldn't but that's my line my
line is like no
no I've seen it happen too many times
girl goes back cheats some more I would
rather just not look like a clown what
would you say most girls go back after
they get cheated on some not all what
percent how many friends do you know
that have gotten cheated on
uh
um all of them
a couple but it was the situation that
they had been in so let's say if it
involved kids obviously they want to put
the kids first you know I mean um no I
know there's reasons I'm just curious
yeah but I don't think I think after
they've been cheated on once they start
where I'm such a
type of person I am and the way I handle
things obviously the people around me
they've done dumb stupid things like
I've done stupid things in the past
but I just feel like how many how many
friends of yours have gotten cheated on
full so so two three yeah three three
and how many stayed with him after he
cheated
um two two but they've not they're not
with them anymore right I just meant
like when they cheated they stayed yeah
they stayed with them afterwards but
then they left like obviously yeah yeah
later yeah
proves my point
um okay uh
I don't even remember the original
question because you haven't been down
here yet no I know because I was
thinking would you remember the question
yeah it was something to the type of men
I think it was
have you separated from men or how many
men have you seen yes yeah how many
breakups have you initiated and why
so my
first one
I left but it nearly cost me my life
um my second one I
it was I was seeing someone and he
was seeing other women so that ended
um and my third one I was just a huge
secret
so that ended in November
so like his family and friends didn't
know about you so no okay so you felt
like you wanted something more serious
and it was more casual for him yeah I
think so
um it was four years that I was with him
so if you don't mind me asking how did
you almost lose your life in the first
one
uh
domestic abuse
physical abuse
um
all abuse
yeah I was basically isolated
um
come on big question on live TV
yeah that's I have accounts in for it um
I've got two beautiful girls
um amazing girls who blessed me with
those
um certainly taught me a lesson huge one
and one that nearly cost me in my life
um
but yeah I was with him for a long time
I don't know why I stayed I think
mentally and emotionally I think abusers
have a way of
the physical disappears
the mental and emotional abuse stays
um
I was so isolated from everybody and I
think in terms of
I only had him and his family so it was
quite difficult and I think
the good was good
the bad was horrific
so
um were you able to press charges
I didn't for a very long time but I
don't think
I dealt with it and healed from it until
years later
um in fact it was only up until a few
years ago so I finally left in 2010.
um
so 13 years ago and I only really dealt
with it and got support for it about
five five years ago and dealt with it so
I think it was
I up and moved the police removed me
from my home
um it was going to go to court we did go
to court
um they said I wouldn't see him at court
I did see him at court and then that's
when I withdrew all my statements so he
still got prosecuted I think now they
can prosecute yeah um
but at the time that wasn't the case I
think he just he got a fine in probation
and community service and stuff like
that so
um and I think for me they told me I was
looking at five years and we had two
girls so you wanted him to not that I
wanted him back but I just thought for
the girls right but now looking back
that was the wrong decision I think he's
gone on to have multiple abusive
relationships since so but um my girls
have had nothing to do with him so
kind of yeah yeah my youngest one did
seek him out but
he's not changed so um she no longer
wants a relationship with him my eldest
one remembers too much
definitely doesn't want anything to do
with him at this stage but I would never
not promote that I think that's
something that they would need to make a
decision for at the time I stopped them
from having that relationship for their
own safety and mine
um I've never stopped it in terms of if
you wanted to do it
properly and on the legal route
um supervised contact absolutely but
he's never wanted to take that so
um it was all about control and and
about me so the times that he did have
contact with the girls in the early
years when I left
he would be screaming at the girls for
them to put me on the phone so it was
never really about the girls anyway so
so yeah so that was my first one
thank you for sharing that
um okay I'm I'm curious like how many
years were you with him before you left
was it did you say seven so from the age
of 18 to
28. oh wow wow that's a long time yeah
so just because I'm always just curious
like when did you realize he was abusive
so it was gradual so after probably
about the first eight months seven
months eight months
um
but it was little things can't go out
didn't want me to go to work but made it
made me feel like it was I was doing
something wrong all the time having male
friends why have you got so many male
friends just yeah it's the Ice Station
why are you wearing that that doesn't
look nice on you you don't need to wear
heels today why have you got makeup on
you're going just little things
you know I come down in something that I
want to wear I don't really look nice
babe why don't go change it
little things but then obviously
past relationships his own insecurities
obviously knowing people that I had had
a relationship with previously
we could be watching telly it could be
anything that triggered him it didn't
matter what it was then
um but physically
yeah about after about seven eight
months
wow
so what what made you stay that long
good question
good question I don't know
I don't know the good times were good I
think in terms of
I don't have any real answer maybe I
thought I loved him I thought he loved
me
um
always sorry he would always be sorry
for the things that happened and
make things up buy things take me out
say nice things to me pillow talk I
guess if you like
um
yeah I feel like in situations like that
if you don't mind me just seeing what
I'm about to say but it's kind of like
when you've experienced such lows any
high will seem like the happiest thing
on Earth for you and it will make you
want to stay so it doesn't matter like
how however long how long they've been
together how long bad stuff has been
happening but if the high is high then
you are going to stay believe it or not
it's going to take a lot of Detachment
it's going to take a lot of like
self-discipline for you to be like for
you to kind of go this High isn't the
high we want this this high is only High
because the lows have been sold like I
disagree I I disagree someone that's
been a similar situation sometimes you
never know what day the week is let
alone high as a high and it's all about
picking away at you so by the end of it
you've got no identity his partner and
the kid's mum and these things creep up
on you I mean I put up with it for I
think less than a year but and in my day
you call the police he was like oh it's
a domestic they've never done anything
in those days so they're probably for 10
years wow I had police at my house the
police just come regular and just say oh
it's a domestic I need this leave I need
to hang them in there you're supposed to
take him with you
I never did the only most you're going
to get out of your Social Services so
back then it wasn't even that no but you
didn't even get that back there was
nothing then and I mean I I didn't have
my son then when I did have my son and I
thought that's it I'm out of there yeah
but it's like especially when things
happen around his family not yours and
that's the weird thing is you feed
yourself how can you have a family and
they know what's going on but they won't
do anything and then you realize that
the whole family's scared of them yes
that's one thing that's going to ask him
was this family kind of complicit in the
abuse they knew what was going on and
they just turned a blind eye or was it
secret to them
they were aware they didn't condone it
um there was one incident where his his
mum did say that
she's there that brought him into the
world she'll be there to take him take
him out obviously but that was because
it was right in front of her
um
majority of the time I would spend time
at his mum's
um In fairness and she was amazing and
she was she's been in a great amazing
grandmother
um to the girls so
they they know their identity they know
where they come from and they know his
entire family the only person that
they've not had contact with is him
um so that's their choice as an adult
whether they want to go back there or
not
um
my elders remember stuff she shared
stuff with her younger sister I've had
to try and protect her younger sister
from that but they are sisters they will
talk yeah I won't lie to them
but I don't need to divulge anymore that
it's not been said if that makes sense
so that's
how did you break it off because when I
went to work breaking off like how did
you actually break off
I went into a woman's Refuge okay you've
done the midnight flip I did had a bad
bad ready
the first so the first time I was
removed by the police
um they came and removed me and they
took me to my mum's but then after a few
months
I went back but there was a
normalization order in place he wasn't
allowed in certain in the area he wasn't
allowed back at the property but then as
time lapsed
two years later
I put myself back into a woman's Refuge
um and just left
and then I've never looked back and I
was like am I allowed to add a really
good judge that done an injunction out
with a clause but they wanted in order
to cancel the injunction we both have to
be at court
hi and it's 37 years late and I don't
think you realize it still standing I
mean there's no trouble now but it still
stands no I didn't I didn't he wasn't
allowed in the area but it was only for
a period of time
um I can't I think it was about six
months maybe even a year but he breached
out anyway but
um when I went back the second time I
just 21st January 2010.
never look back
cut my hair changed everything about me
amazing so yeah
then the second one that was a
three-year relationship but that was
wasn't really going anywhere I wasn't it
was just
something for me at the time I think I
had the girls it wasn't something that I
was really looking to commit to anyway
but
I found out he was seeing multiple women
so it just kind of ended but my last one
I do love him still
um but it's not worked out I'm not
prepared to be a secret for any longer
um C'est La Vie it is what it is we move
on did you just say right it's finished
now there's been a lot of back and forth
um
we've just not spoke
um he knows how I feel about certain
things so
we've just not communicated would you
say you like bad boys it seems like all
of the guys you pick seem to be bad boys
what's a bad boy like non-committal
multiple girls I mean usually I wouldn't
say the majority of bad boys are abusive
but in her case that would probably
qualify
I think sometimes we can pick partners
that are
possibly a reflection of how we feel
about ourselves sometimes or what we're
missing
um
I don't know I'm work I'm on a I'm on a
journey at the moment I'm healing and
I'm learning a lot about myself and
about
I'm doing a lot of inner child work I'm
looking at myself going back through my
history why do I pick the men
that I have I do come from a broken home
is it generational is it one of those
things that just my upbringings impacted
that the influences around I I don't
know I'm doing a lot of work on that at
the moment because I do think it does
impact on our decision making and our
judgments
[Music]
um
how we brought up how childhood I think
it plays a huge part
um and how we develop just to put a
smile in your face but it's a serious
question still smiling she was a
Christian would you would you get
together with a vegetarian
a vegetarian yeah
he was like
you're perfect guy and he said I'm a
vegetarian
it's not perfect
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
that's a young lady about dumping men
how many relationships have um you ended
and why
are we like three or four
um
I think most of it is like
not
what I want I guess like it's just not
working or they're just
I like when someone knows the diff
obviously I like someone that does isn't
too serious all the time but I feel like
knowing when to be serious is so
important so that's like one of the big
things for me
and what about the other ones
yeah it's just don't get along or one I
actually end up falling in love with
someone else
so cut that off
how did that start was it someone you
knew like a guy friend oh no actually it
was a girlfriend
yeah we just became friends
friendship like we got closer as friends
um and then yeah
I didn't expect that um
you're saying that I can see everybody
like and I'm thinking what the hell
it's hard to say it I was shocked
shocked everyone always is I don't know
why like what is it no because this is
the way you know we're all talking I
think you just naturally explain yeah we
just expressed it actually and then when
you said it it's like I noticed that you
could hear a pin drop and I thought
did he know you were bi I didn't know
she didn't know yeah I was just thinking
like he really didn't see that he's like
I lost my girl
I'd be pissed I had a few minutes I
didn't see that coming have you guys
ever dated a guy and he turned to out he
swung for the other team no yeah no but
who said yes yes
how did you find out
a couple people and
um let's just say the streets the
streets talk the streets talk you know
everything
so you heard through the grapevine he
was like hooking up with dudes
that and I've seen obviously things
myself obviously at first I was a bit
suspicious and then you know did that
particular sexual positions I just want
to put it out there nicely
I have to ask people out there
because you
know they're more freaking out they're
much more freakier much more dirty I
just said don't say dirty don't say
dirty
but I like that okay
um weirdly
would you go if somebody that a bisexual
person again yeah I would okay
I would they have to be male or female
both
I sleep with girls as well so okay I'm
not saying that no date so I'm just
asking
um out of the breakups are there any
breakups that you considered a win and
why
all of them all of them yeah you always
did better after
better okay yeah yeah yeah
were there any that you considered a
loss
one
one yeah my baby dad probably
um not him no
did he go on to date someone else no
he's not I think it's just in terms of
like
him as a man
probably like one of the best I'm going
to get so now that that's not there I
think that's where I've kind of
got a loss because do you think um him
being your baby that influences that a
lot more
influences what just the fact that you
you feel like he was like the best you
can get
um
so if you didn't have the kid would you
still feel the exact same meals you're
feeling right now yeah because I just
feel like in terms of the qualities that
he has as a man
is it too late for years too okay
I don't know if he's watching this
he's Brave go out there I want you back
[Laughter]
yeah yeah Auntie Jenny is actually
Auntie Jenny's actually doing counseling
now as a YouTube show so if you want to
bring something yeah oh I think it can
work I think that you see the difference
is right when you when you have somebody
like that and you got that same kind of
feeling what you need to do is go back
and sit down and talk about what went
wrong what you could have said
and nine times out of 10 you find that
as a woman you need to apologize because
you didn't let him be a man and I can
tell by your face that he was right and
you was wrong that's why you're often
because you realize that you left up
yeah
am I right or am I right I say like 80
yeah okay then let's take that
that was impressive
it's all the meditation
[Laughter]
back with you
tomorrow I mean
it's not that I don't like him but I
just feel like there's certain things
that because he's only one I'm 25 he's
going to be 20. 7 27 or 28. so he's not
that much older than me but I feel like
in in a lot of in like 70 of ways he's
so mature and then there's that 30 where
he's just so immature loving that that's
the fun bit are you are you immature at
times you don't think you're ever
immature he's not God
you know what she needs to do she needs
to think to herself whatever he was
serious 100 of the time
that's what you need to think Effie was
only a hundred percent of the time you
wouldn't feel the same way now
and you might not like you might not
think so now but those fun bits what
made him the whole person no I do like
it I just feel like there's a time and
like I said earlier there's a time and
place when you need to be serious maybe
you just need to cheat and go with it
have fun maybe you're just too serious
you know maybe since you had the child
you just got serious all of a sudden you
did something understand what's wrong
with you you've got a child
do you want do you want more kids yeah
definitely with him I wouldn't be mad if
he was the dad but obviously I want to
find like
my right man and then that is your right
man
over your face I
I feel like when we say the right you
pick the right guy there's not like one
one person out there for you she just
don't want to put in the hard work to
make him perfect
but is that my responsibility to make
you perfect though is it his
responsibility to make you perfect I
mean a lot of things
do you have a cookbook
I mean with your own recipes that you've
made yourself
what'd you mean you know what I mean
it's okay that was okay it's you don't
have to but I'm saying like if you know
if you're gonna criticize and say it's
my job to make him perfect it's like am
I perfect yeah so I feel like it depends
on who it is I feel like there comes
with it has there's something in a
relationship when two people are
immature and you're aware of it it comes
and established like thing well how cool
we're going to be immature but we know
when to like you said when to act right
and and it's also like it determines
like what what is the right time to act
to act right who determines that
both both parties got to you have to be
in a consensus for for anything but what
if you disagree
I follow you couldn't you couldn't agree
to disagree too
right but the whole point is you may
look at a situation and see it as he
needs to be serious now but he might
think that he doesn't have to then he
took it out and you'll be like listen I
don't appreciate it but what what was
Ashley trying to say and I was trying to
say that
some people will be immature to you by
feeling mature to them they can't take
it
so it's kind of like now you're stuck in
a position where you can't be immature
and now every time they're immature it's
kind of like that this is not the right
time you see that's why you don't play
games in relationships see that's what I
was trying to get because no having fun
and playing games is different
he was having fun what you describing is
playing games there's a big difference
because he was just being himself
um and she knows it was just being
himself so I'm in the foolish sometimes
let my friend I'm sure that women are
stupid sometimes too and they allow you
we're creating a new therapy Studio they
need to be able to handle the truth
tissues will be supplied
advice you're stuffing it
it's tough you know what I'm always
right so I'm proven wrong
um
so you want to prove me wrong fair
enough but I know that I can get you and
your man working yeah that might need
you right now and get the next baby
yeah yeah we could do a couple episodes
yeah I mean yeah I want to see her on
that Vlog yeah
let's hear The Men's yeah
[Laughter]
for them I think that once if you need
to shut up and listen to me you should
you tell a few home truths you can bring
the musician too we can get you guys
[Laughter]
you you thought was the right thing to
do I mean but with hindsight would you
if he wasn't a musician what else could
he have been he was a architectural
metal worker in the airports and he was
miserable and I wanted him to be happy
okay so to be happy
he left his job and he took a risk and I
encouraged that it didn't work out good
for him financially majorly so yeah oh
that's all right then we'll use that are
still friends and that's all right he
ain't got no kids without you yeah oh
you have well that's all right then he's
making money you got kids and you're
getting on that's great yeah
no arguments that's always good I really
I really think we could do a double
episode I really think we can just bring
families together in the theory
[Laughter]
do you know what I'd really like to do
I'd like to I'd like to follow her and
I'd like to check out her um
Style
because I reckon she's giving off the
wrong
I'd like to know that with wife Scott
I'd like to make her over and see the
difference this young lady here
I think she's giving out all the wrong
signal yeah that's it
yeah I think she's attracting the wrong
type of person because she's giving out
the wrong signals
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible